[Musique]
ce qui est important de retenir dans
notre vie c'est que il faut toujours
faire ce qu'on aime
c'est très important il faut toujours
faire ce qu'on aime et lorsqu'on fait ce
qu'on aime on fait la chose sans
souffrance
sans douleur et au bout du compte on
réussit
nous avons été mis ici qui est assez
important donc nous parlons du
patrimoine
bon moi je suis du patrimoine même si je
n'ai pas eu d'héritage réel
en termes de bien ou en terme d'éléments
culturels
nous parlons également de transmission à
travers ce thème donc au niveau du sous
thème de transmission
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas
suffisamment de transmission de valeur
vis-à-vis de nos enfants
vis-à-vis de ce que nous encadrons
mais nous avons besoin de nous mettre à
jour culturellement nous avons besoin de
nous mettre à jour dans notre façon de
faire dans notre façon de vivre et dans
notre façon d'éduquer nos enfants
j'ai une histoire assez particulière
je viens d'une famille où il n'y a pas
d'artistes
personne est artiste une famille
également qui n'est pas riche aisé
et très peu bizarrement moi je dessinais
le destiné très bien au primaire au
collège
pourtant j'étais en même temps pas mal
comme on le dit un des meilleurs élèves
dans les matières littéraires dans les
matières philosophiques
mais je continue de dessiner mais juste
peut-être par passion par amusement ou
bien parce que certains dons mais je
dessinais
et une fois au collège
il s'est trouvé que lorsqu'on devait
faire les orientations
pour aller faire le
la série littéraires ou scientifiques
comme on le dit à C ainsi de suite
moi j'ai choisi d'aller faire les arts
parce qu'à l'époque il y avait une série
qu'on appelait la série à 3 qui a été
supprimé parce que ça nous a vraiment
maltraité et on a trois on avait les
arts et la philosophie mais avec des
moyens mais difficile de coefficients de
7 de 5 on avait au moins trois quatre
matières d'histoire histoire générale
histoire-géographie histoire de la
occidentale histoire de l'art africain
j'étais très compliqué donc personne ne
voulait laisser ses enfants partir
là-bas
et à l'école j'ai été le seul dans ma
promotion a choisi cette série là
mon professeur principal me convoque toi
c'est là tu vas aller faire
premier point après le surveillance
général également me convient
mais on a appris que dans les choix là
pour les orientations toi tu as mis ah
est-ce que tu es normal
mais bon moi je m'amuse avec je dessine
bon je pense que ça peut m'aider
et par extraordinaire de nos profs qui
étaient un professeur stagiaire un jeune
prof qui arrive et qui devait nous
prendre que nous dit ben je vais vous
envoyer quelque part vous allez
découvrir un peu ce qui se fait il nous
envoie à Lina à l'époque c'était Lina on
arrive à Lina je vois des dessins des
gens qui dessinent qui font des
portraits qui font des choses
extraordinaires
et après je m'assois je dis mais moi je
prends pour m'amuser on dit tu es fort
mais les gens ils prennent ça pour faire
ils utilisent cela comme un métier ils
étudient cela à l'école donc le choix
que je voulais faire est un très bon
choix
quand les parents ont appris également
la nouvelle on dit mais toi c'est dessin
tu veux faire il faut aller docteur
officiel juge mais c'est ce qui se passe
dans nos familles on aime les métiers de
sécurité si tu es docteur si les gens
sont malades tu vas les soigner
si tu es dans l'armée ou bien tu es
juges si tes parents ont les problèmes
tu vas les protéger tu vas les secourir
donc ça a été très compliqué
donc seul je suis parti et j'arrive dans
cette école je me rends compte qu'il y a
les gens qui ont fait une école qui
existait à benguru qu'on appelle l'école
des Arts aussi on se retrouve dans la
même classe
cette histoire là ça va chauffer je suis
venu là mais il y a des gens qui ont
déjà fait l'art avant moi et on se
retrouve au même endroit
mais comme je l'ai dit au départ
il faut toujours faire ce qu'on aime et
quand on fait ce qu'on aime on arrive
toujours à s'en sortir et quand on fait
cette chose avec passion avec amour avec
persévérance on s'en sort toujours
malgré la crainte et la difficulté que
j'avais vis-à-vis de mes amis
au bout du compte
j'ai été parmi les trois meilleurs de ma
promotion lorsqu'on sortait
et là je dis bon
ça s'est très bien passé il faut aller
faire maintenant les beaux-arts donc les
études supérieures donc j'arrive au
Beaux-Arts toujours nous c'était inaen à
l'époque c'est venu après au début des
années 90
et j'arrive à l'école des Beaux-Arts
mais j'avais compris une chose c'est que
en général les gens attendaient de finir
pour se faire connaître
je me suis dit non mais le chemin est
long après de 6 années d'études après le
bac c'est long c'est comme si tu vas te
faire doctorat et je vais attendre après
en tant qu'artiste pour me faire
connaître je ne veux pas moi je vais
commencer du coup je me suis engagé à
participer à des petits événements de
petites expositions quand il y a des
événements au quartier je vais quand les
gens disent qu'il est un salon une fois
quel que soit l'activité je m'y mets
et un jour j'ai rencontré quelqu'un un
grand mécène qui me dit mais j'entends
parler de toi tu fais des portraits tu
exposes en des petits endroits et tout
ça mais moi je vais te soutenir je vais
t'accompagner le diable qu'est-ce que tu
veux il dit mais je vais faire une
exposition
je suis en 3e année c'est pas encore
fini donc licence 3 et moi je vais faire
une exposition officielle pourtant à
l'école c'était interdit
donc je m'engage nostalgie venait
d'arriver
en effet une grande campagne je passe à
la télé et tout ça tout content j'arrive
à l'école le matin on dit à la star toi
tu es devenu star tu dois plus mettre
tes pieds dans cette école parce que tu
es devenu star
je dis mais
quand on fait là ça se fait connaître
non on dit oui c'est fait connaître mais
parler attendre la fin pour te faire
connaître toi tu es déjà devenu star tu
es déjà devenu un maître c'est bon reste
dehors
ça a été très très très compliqué
et là c'était certains enseignants que
je croyais être maître mais ami et tout
ça qui ont monté la Kabbale donc les
gens avaient décidé de me faire partir
et à l'examen de fin d'année on me met
des notes bizarres
et je vais voir l'administration je dis
mais je ne comprends pas je suis quand
même un de vos meilleurs étudiants
il se trouve comme maître illuminatoires
comment je fais et donc l'administration
me dit mes accords tu connais il faut te
calmer ce qu'ils veulent faire là ça va
pas marcher du coup ça m'a rassuré
donc la liste sort pour les résultats
je suis recalé mais l'administration
prend l'initiative de me faire venir
pour pouvoir composer et donner mes
travaux à d'autres enseignants qui ne
sont pas dans la Kabbale en question
qu'ils étaient organisés contre moi il
faut toujours faire ce qu'on aime et
quand on fait ce que vous aimez que vous
le faites bien vous aurez toujours des
gens bien aussi pour vous accompagner
pour vous soutenir
et c'est comme ça que j'ai échappé
à la Kabbale qui était présenté contre
moi mais là encore il y avait un petit
problème parce que le jour on me
demandait de venir composer un peu en
secret là
les gens nous ont attaqué universitaire
c'était la période où les gendarmes les
policiers tombaient toujours assister
pour chicoter les gens et j'ai une
fracture au pied
pourtant l'administration m'a dit viens
on va te prendre de côté tu vas
travailler donc j'appelle
l'administration je dis mais là je viens
d'avoir une fracture comment je fais on
dit débrouille-toi même si c'est avec
des béquilles ou bien si c'est
d'ambulance arrive dans cette école on
va s'arranger
dont je me débrouille avec mes béquilles
tout ça j'arrive on dit
pour la première fois un étudiant
composant
dans son dos
mais juste parce que on savait très bien
que c'est quelqu'un qui aimait bien son
travail et qui aimait très bien faire
son travail aux examens de fin d'année
chez nous ce qu'on faisait
habituellement c'est que il faut
présenter son travail mais après il faut
exposer aussi ces travaux
moi je venais avec une Bassée ou un
camion rempli de tableaux de sculptures
de décoration de choses donc du coup
quand je finis d'exposer toutes les amis
de classe fui on dit ah l'homme elle est
venue garder encore comment nous on va
s'arranger pour venir exposer après lui
et donc les choses se sont bien passées
je continuais dans ma trajectoire et
lorsqu'on a fini
il s'est trouvé que la Côte d'Ivoire
devait participer à un événement très
important aux États-Unis Atlanta donc au
ministère de la Culture on m'appelle on
dit à toi on te connaît tu travailles
bien et tout ça on te met dans le groupe
tu vas partir avec les gens donc prépare
des oeufs tu viens avec des tableaux tu
vas participer donc je rassemble mes
tableaux je vais pour l'enregistrement
pouvoir participer
j'arrive je vois un de nos anciens là
les doyens à l'époque des peintres il me
voyait trois petits là tu viens chercher
au milieu de nous ici
parce qu'on dit qu'on va aux États-Unis
toi tu veux te mettre dedans
tu es trop jeune ça c'est pour nous les
vieux d'abord
donc j'appelle au ministère je dis mais
vous m'avez dit de venir avec mes
affaires je suis arrivé les vieux là mon
chasser donc ils appellent
il est responsable lui dire les doyens
en question lui leur dites
s'il part nous on ne va plus
c'est extraordinaire s'il part aussi
nous on ne va plus
donc du coup on m'appelle on dit bon
pour ne pas qu'il y a un scandale Jacob
il faut te retirer
les doyens vont aller faire l'exposition
et puis les choses vont bien se passer
donc je me suis retiré avec mes affaires
j'ai ramassé sorti comme un vulgaire
bonhomme je suis rentré chez moi
mais après cela ce qui s'est passé c'est
que les oeuvres sont arrivés non
seulement en retard pour l'événement
c'est rester dans les containers
tout à tout a été détérioré par
l'humidité donc quelque part dieu m'a
sauvé dans toutes les affaires qu'ils
ont envoyé là ont été gâtés c'est rester
dans continuer dans le froid ça c'est
ils n'ont pas pu faire l'événement ils
n'ont pas pu partir convenablement
et les jours qui ont suivi
98 on dit bon on fait un pavillon pour
la Côte d'Ivoire tu diras au nom de la
Côte d'Ivoire
ça commence bien cette histoire là donc
j'appelle maintenant à la maison je dis
vous voyez mon affaire
États-Unis mais là on m'envoie déjà à
Dakar ok donc
ça se passe très bien et après ça
s'enchaîne jeu de la francophonie au
Canada 2001 je vais représenter la Côte
d'Ivoire tout commence à bien se passer
et après les choses se sont enseignées à
force de travailler les choses ont
commencé à sanctionner mais ce qui est
important pour nous et qui a un lien
nécessaire avec le thème que nous avons
le patrimoine c'est que pour nous qui
avons grandi et vécu pratiquement à
Abidjan
il fallait faire un retour aux sources
du coup j'ai décidé de promouvoir ma
culture de travailler sur nos masses de
travailler sur nos danse de travailler
sur nos musiques et mes travaux en
général sont autour de ça
et au-delà de ça j'ai décidé également
de m'engager dans la promotion des
artistes donc tous les événements dont
on parle festival ici que j'organise des
événements que j'organise mais c'est
parti des frustrations que j'ai eu parce
que les gens à notre époque nous
empêchaient d'éclore nous empêchaient de
nous positionner donc je me suis dit non
si moi demain j'ai la possibilité que
j'ai un minimum de moyens je vais aider
les jeunes du coup je mets des
événements en place pour accompagner les
jeunes j'ai deux galeries d'art à
Abidjan une galerie en collaboration en
partenariat avec Bénédicte à la
Fondation Béji Gadet
nous accompagnons les artistes nous
soutenons les créateurs parce que nous
avons un vécu qui est quand même
douloureux et ne faudrait pas que les
jeunes de mains souffrent aussi comme
nous avons besoin d'aimer ce que nous
faisons et si nous le faisons bien et
convenablement nous irons très loin
aujourd'hui nous sommes contents parce
que les œuvres des artistes africains
ont commencé à avoir de la côte on a un
jeune ivoirien qui a vendu il y a pas
longtemps un tableau à 300 millions
c'est pas
un autre qui a vendu un tableau après de
200 millions
aujourd'hui tout le monde tourne vers ce
tourne vers le continent africain pour
ses richesses mais aussi pour sa culture
il faut aimer ce qu'on fait et de
décourageant par nos enfants je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]